e allora tua madre bella tutti ragazzi e
benvenuti a questo video sono vari j
volevo dirvi che ho intenzione di
prendermi una per farmi che sto per fare
fantastico poi però io cosa ho fatto in
partenza ma se riuscivo a faccia cosa la
partenza migliore di slitte rio della
storia va bene ma devo dirvi ragazzi e
questo molto probabilmente sarà l'ultimo
episodio estivo di stavo scherzando farò
un sacco di altri video su questo gioco
fantastico sofia
se prima sofia proprio biscardi viscardi
se prima lei devo arriva il primo c'è
non esiste
arriva primo io fermi tutti una
questione di vita o di morte new pokémon
capitan america ma non avevo dubbi come
lo [ __ ] forte e va beh sono un
fenomeno regga su youtube un fenomeno il
record di velocità né ad arrivare primi
fermi tutti con questa frase che ho
detto muoio macos ho fatto vai veloce
veloce veloce non ci posso credere è
assurdo devo arrivare assolutamente tra
i primi record di velocità nell'arrivare
primo c'è l'amore che roba sono quasi
primo non entrerò neanche in classifica
dopo sta cosa che dico è però burqa e va
così è morto quando si scattato quello
levati dai [ __ ] verme lurido ok
perfetto sono quasi in classifica ma su
questo ce l'ho fatta ho fatto non ci
posso credere che culo
vai vai vai vai vai vai vai vai vai in
un buon non morire non morirà adesso di
uno scritto tu pure quello porca eva
sono quanto settimo sesto sesto round in
un secondo papà dal ci credo io volevo
dire non ancora neanche introdotto il
video sono sesto va bene perché quelli
che ce l'hanno grosso ce l'hanno grosso
subito a percentuale di doppi sensi da
quando introdotto slither io né i miei
video aumentata del 100 per cento
porca vacca vi stanno schiantando male
sono terzo sono terzo deve morire il
primo che il primo e sonic ragazzi
volevo dirvi che probabilmente sarà
l'ultimo episodio estivo di svizzeri che
speriamo che vada bene come l'ultimo
episodio estivo nicchia partito la
guerra li guarda lì
workshop dovete togliermi sono i miei
punti l'ho ucciso io olimpiadi 2016 va
bene quindi se ti uccido prendo una
medaglia zio cosa succede se si è cagato
addosso ti devi toglierti dai fratello
ucciso io in oriente ha ucciso il tizio
brogli o spinto il tizio che ha ucciso
lui quindi che il picchio il cane
demorso degli atto car mercato tuo padre
se ne a marzo uno qualsiasi sono prima è
morto anche sonic sono primo in velocità
di slip c'è nel senso questo sommesso
minuto meno che non riesca inglobare
questa fermi niente ragazzo ha provato e
dovevo provarci perché ci avevo messo la
mente un secondo ad arrivare terzo
quindi però è stata nemmeno giocarla e
quando dora l'esploratrice arriva prima
e tu no chi fai delle domande di vita
cosa fa questo ciclo by scemo
vabbè ma non è possibile cosa cosa sto
facendo oggi madonna quanto forte quanto
fortis episodio va bene sto facendo da
eurobic non ho mai fatti tutta la mia
vita grazie gioco per avere sempre il
tempismo giusto per fargli fare figure
di merda e quello sbagliato per farmi
fare le belle figure anche a scuola
prendono i bei voti sono alla fine prova
a ribattere al record di nuovo di
velocità ma ne dubito doveva morire mi
uno forte davanti ad esso per danni
morali che ingloba tutti il nuovo tutti
ho deciso
decide lui la partita si fa chi è un è
morto e due no no no no ma sofista
bruttissima ora che mi vuole quest'ora
di wall e questo non mi è morto porca
eva c'era sono sesto ai ragazzi sono
sesto ce la posso fare
che yunus zitto o 15 fottuti episodi di
sto schifo di gioco ancora non ho capito
che devo stare zitto zitto ogni volta
che dico una puttanata del tipo ce la
faccio muoio sempre ora che mi vede
piccole pensa che io non sia la minaccia
però poi gira e fa infatti no no no
volevi niente non c'è riuscito cazzo no
provino avevo fatto schiantare però l'ho
fatto scelta che ho fatto cagare addosso
si è schiantato peccato perché l'idea
era buonissimo c'era neanche pirlo
shasta regia in campo tutto calcolato
tra nella mia morte era tutto calcolato
termiche ci posso riuscire fermi non è
così difficile arrivare primi che ora
almeno oggi che ci sto per noi non
barney server perché non mi serve è così
e mi dice server in school prova con tua
mamma e lo sapevo perché i ragazzi
quando fai dei dei punteggi il gioco
stesso ti dice mark hurd raja e non ti
fa entrare nelle partite sti maledetti
stronzi madonna sono morto con un bot
era un bot quello quindi non sono
giocatori e sono vermi che vanno avanti
a caso cioè sono botte siamo morti in 22
deficienti dove preso perfetto fai vai
vai vai vai vai vai a dire che c'è
questo grandissimo il fototipo a me away
foti punti brutto deficienza effetto lo
sapevo era il karma ora quanti muoiono
di continuo 1 dove pure questo se muore
questo sono contentissimo guarda è morto
con le norme
porca eva e vabbè allargato tuttora
galaga non si capiva un cazzo hai
ultimamente quando muoiono quelli più
grossi lag c'è veramente all'inizio non
c'era sta cosa
qui dove la madonna cosa è successo cosa
è successo no non mi ucciderò incidente
l'ansia santo iddio aveva beh noi
inglobato 1 senza volerlo ma dai raga ma
oggi cosa vi sta succedendo regala che
roba a questo tipo è amore e attenzione
boom no dai va beh non ci credo se poi
ragazzi avete letto nei commenti la vj
non vuole che gli si rubino i punti però
lui gli ruba gli altri è ovvio fai agli
altri quello che vuoi che non sia fatto
a te giusto no non ci va sono un
[ __ ] sono un cogl
ma proprio un [ __ ] ma posso essere
chiusi rinconada non è vero non è
possibile stavo pensando di fare una
cosa poi ho cambiato idea nel mentre mi
sono andato a smartphone deficiente
per la samp vola vola fin su porca eva
chi devi togliere testa di culo che mi
fotte pumbaa rateo bailey rae e o almeno
missori pilato quelli che ho perso io
ora league ora di gara di continuare di
quanti bye bye bye bye bye c'ero quasi
proprio un millisecondo da dove spuntato
quello o per farlo anche ordinato sushi
a [ __ ] riso dovuto tranquillizzare
ga'hoole bisogno ho avuto bisogno di
ordinare il sushi
così sono contento che appena finisco di
co sti cazzo di serpenti mamma magnone
bagno tuto sorella niente poche worm
pokémon verme no no no no no calmi calmi
e già è difficile per carità di dio mi
si sta incamminando tutto il compito del
qualsiasi roba mi rema contro quando lo
fai record aspirapolvere passa niente
proprio morire il criceto di diarrea
spruzzo olè olè ma è la madonna che
dribbling ma come che va fatta
mica incredibile lorca e va così è
successo qua dai raga [ __ ] perché
è perfetto perché è morto che quello mai
viene inglobato cosa stavo facendo
chi stava uccide dai mi chiama che culo
cia questo verde come perfetto non ce la
farò mai a breve ma non ci voglio
credere mi che se riesco inglobare tutti
sti punti ciao ne traeva quanto siano da
chi le voleva il primo fatemi arriva ok
da tesseramenti guerra aperta per
arrivare primi gioco del cazzo perché
non capisco che devo stare zitto nella
vita perché io continuerò a parlà
prossimi tre video li passò in silenzio
fatidico niente lo faccio su tentativo
fermi un attimo
e allora tua madre va bè ragazzi e ci ho
provato è stato un bel tentativo però
concluso che i corsi d'italiano fino a
per questo mese l'ultimo episodio
istituti streeter io perché mi fa troppo
caldo incazzarmi mentre gioco quindi
devo smetterla o mi sciolgo però che vi
sia piaciuto ragazzi spero che la mia
ascella fine vita sia di vostro
gradimento dei ragazzi video bisogno
sono come tu mi piace anche la pagina di
facebook e come invito ad andare
iscrizione cioè se questi scatti di ci
vediamo al prossimo video la ragazza